what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to comics explain where i
make you a comic book expert in 30
minutes or less and in this video i'm
gonna make you guys an expert on the
mandarin from marvel comics now here's a
funny thing if you go and you look up
the origin of the mandarin right now you
will find the most modern origin of the
character but while i don't normally do
this we're actually going to go back and
cover his original origin as well as his
modern origin because the original
origin is kind of significant largely
because it gives you context of the
character more so than the modern day
origin does but uh the mandarin first
made his appearance in marvel comics
with tales of suspense issue number 50
in 1964 and he was created by stan lee
and don heck now the biggest reason why
this happened as opposed to just iron
man number one because he's an iron man
villain largely uh is because tales of
suspense was originally an iron man
comic and then eventually iron man got
his own comic later on down the line but
the origin of the mandarin didn't
immediately come to us which was kind of
a change of pace from what you normally
saw with comics especially during the
1960s normally whenever you saw a
villain introduced or like a new hero
who was introduced like on the avengers
team or in an avengers story and say and
by the way here's how i got my powers
instead with the mandarin it actually
happened about five issues after he
first showed up and again that kind of
makes sense right because with him
appearing in tales of suspense we didn't
really know if there was going to be a
whole lot of interest in his character
now the way the original origin unfolded
for his character it played out in such
a way where it basically told us that at
some point along the line uh the
mandarin was born to what was in effect
a wealthy family but his father ended up
perishing now a lot of this was based on
the idea that it was like a bad omen
just because of the fact that when he
was born literally a giant idol fell on
his dad and killed him and so as a
result of that his aunt essentially his
father's sister was basically jealous of
the mandarin in this idea that he was
essentially inheriting all the wealth
from his family as well as a family
lineage because one of the things it was
established in the early days here is
that the mandarin is a direct descendant
of genghis khan and so it was a way to
kind of tie into the history of china
specifically mongolia and then say
there's a long-standing lineage there
and so the result of this is that the
aunt initially tried to not really kill
the mandarin but basically wrap him up
and then take him to a local village and
leave him there where he would basically
be raised without any knowledge of who
he truly was and she would in turn
inherit all the wealth by just saying
the baby's vanished it's gone who knows
but like i'm the rightful heir now
ultimately an idol fell next to her
which was taken as an omen that
basically the gods had been looking out
for them now right off the bat you can
kind of tell here there's a reason why
this origin was changed one of the
things that was really a big stereotype
when it came to
asia as at least as it was perceived in
the united states is that people from
asia specifically from east asia right
so china japan vietnam places like that
were like highly superstitious and even
in this comic they refer to people of
asian descent as orientals which is a
very antiquated if not borderline racist
term in this day and age and so uh
that's one of the reasons why this
origin was really changed and also
because it's just overly complex but the
result of this is that because this was
was taken as an omen that the child
needs to live in effect every ounce of
the family's money was basically spent
teaching him everything he needed to
know about the world sciences and
specifically how to become a villain the
results of this is that the family never
paid their taxes and so when time came
due the government basically seized
their land and kicked them out and so as
a result of this the mandarin basically
wandered the streets as a homeless man
when his aunt had essentially died the
next day and even when he was working in
the fields he always maintained this air
of having an exceedingly proud history
and basically walked as if he was a
nobleman despite having no nobility
whatsoever right no wealth no land none
of that stuff and so ultimately his
travels bring him to a place called the
valley of spirits which he was initially
warned not to travel to by a local
villager but took it as a sign that it
was a kind of a destiny for himself
right that he needed to find out what
was going on there and then ultimately
came across what he saw as a glowing
light and so once he made his way to
this valley of the spirits he came
across this giant you know dragon
skeleton kind of fell and then stumbled
across a spaceship and that's when you
end up learning this kind of dragon is
not really a dragon in the traditional
sense and it was one of the ways that
marvel teased the idea of dragons in the
early days simply just offering this
explanation that dragons in the
traditional sense as we know them may or
may not exist instead it was basically
this guy being what's called a mcluhan
in the sense that he comes from a planet
called maklu4 and had literally just
gone into the end of the universe
exploring to see if there was other life
other intelligent life outside their own
and while he had stumbled across
different planets and worlds and so on
it was only when he arrived on earth and
met the primitive nature of humanity
that humanity was fearful and then
basically mortally wounded this guy he
took off to a cave and then ultimately
died and so during this time when the
mandarin is just kind of listening to
this entire story while he's on this
spaceship he ends up discovering the
ship's source of power which comes in
the form of 10 rings and so by getting
these 10 rings he basically masters all
these different abilities or at least
these rings you know present him with
different abilities and then he in turn
goes forward and actually starts
conquering the local village and then
coming to this realization that because
of the power he possesses and the fact
that people don't fully understand it
they revere him as much of as somebody
of superstitious legend as a person
who's powerful right and so the results
of this is he just kind of realizes i
can go forward and actually start
conquering things and so that basically
led into his first conflict with iron
man now in more recent years underwriter
matt fraction with iron man annual
number one and iron man uh issue number
522 what we actually ended up finding
out is a couple different things the
first is that in terms of his
traditional origin it was altered so
that he never really knew who his father
was and is and he was basically born to
a english prostitute in an opium den and
so ultimately he's just kind of forced
into a life of child labor when his
mother dies he kills her pimp and then
in turn with the chinese revolution
reigning strong he ultimately ends up
escaping to the mountains the the valley
of the spirits where he discovers the
ship of uh of axe and car now one of the
big differences here is that in this
particular origin this newer origin axon
car was actually alive it wasn't really
a skeleton he was basically dying from
his injuries but he was alive and he
ultimately pleaded with the mandarin to
help him and then the mandarin realized
that the ship was powered by what passes
basically being rings took the rings for
himself killed axon carr and then went
back and started conquering local
villages now during this time he also
started studying the power of the 10
rings and learning what each individual
ring was capable of what each of these
rings could do and if you guys are
curious about the rings themselves i've
actually got a video over a geek culture
explained that kind of runs over them
but the important thing here is that
once he mastered what these rings were
capable of which really gave him a
variety of abilities a couple things
happened the first is that he actually
started subjugating local villages
around him and even kind of christened a
bit of a location for himself kind of a
base of operations and the second thing
was that the rings themselves were
actually imbued with long dead spirits
they were always trying to find a way to
resurrect themselves by using the
mandarin to do so so it was largely kind
of a subplot and it was one of the
things it was used to sort of explain
why it is the mandarin was always
looking to attain extreme levels of
power because it wasn't necessarily his
will he was being bent to the will of
the spirits within the rings but one of
the big questions that fans had at this
time is what do we do about the original
origin
if the original if this is kind of the
new origin that's there how do we
reconcile this with the previous one and
so what matt fraction did is and
specifically he did this invincible iron
man annual number one as he established
this idea that because of his history
regarding the mandarin himself that he
wanted a story to have more grandiosity
and a lot of that was predicated on the
history of the mandarin in the sense
that he was very much a narcissist and
wanted to be seen in the best possible
light and so matt fraction essentially
established that these origins that had
appeared over the years specifically his
original origin was basically
manufactured by the mandarin that it
wasn't actually his origin his real
origin was the one that matt fraction
established that he was born to a hooker
and an opium den and that the whole
story of him being a descendant of
genghis khan and so on and so forth that
he basically just made that up for the
purpose of making himself seem more
important than he actually was but
regardless going back to his original
appearances in marvel comics one of the
funny things that was done here is that
in order to make the mandarin compelling
and in order to make him interesting
what had happened is stan lee and don
heck had actually wrapped his story into
the original origin of tony stark and
the idea and this is one of the big
differences between the comics and the
the film in the film the whole idea
behind the ten rings and all that kind
of stuff is it was basically a modern
day depiction of wartime right so that's
why you saw tony stark becoming iron man
in the middle east as opposed to in
vietnam like it was originally in the
comics but in the comic books the
warlord that it basically captured tony
stark forced him to originally build
weapons which led to tony stark and uh
and ho jensen building like what was in
effect the mark 1 iron man suit there
was a guy named wong chu and what you
end up learning here is that the
mandarin was essentially behind it all
that he was operating behind the scenes
and nobody knew what was happening that
in fact because of the fact that tony
stark was so well known as a weapons
manufacturer and because the mandarin
was looking to expand his sphere of
influence by basically kidnapping tony
stark forcing him to build weapons and
then using those weapons to essentially
conquer even more area around him kind
of expanding his influence in the in
that region of the world this led to him
working alongside wong chu and then
having tony stark brought to vietnam
captured and then forced to build
weapons of course as we know it led to
tony stark basically escaping and then
becoming iron man and so the first real
confrontation that you actually saw
between the mandarin and iron man
himself doesn't really take place until
the mandarin's real first appearance in
the tales of suspense comics now the way
this played out is that because of the
fact that mandarin presented a credible
threat to the western world due to his
desire to basically conquer the world
and the fact that he was pretty powerful
in his own right this led to the cia
bringing in iron man who at the time was
believed to be the bodyguard of tony
stark and then ultimately he was
air-dropped into the mandarin's castle
now a fight kind of ensued where tony
stark worked his way up so it was very
similar to like the game of death any of
you guys ever saw that movie with bruce
lee back in the day where he kind of
works his way up to the top of the
castle is very similar to that and
ultimately there's attempts made by the
mandarins forces to study tony stark's
armor to actually reverse engineer it
while tony stark was temporarily
unconscious of course it doesn't really
work but during the final battle between
the mandarin and stark stark realizes
the mandarin and basically tampered with
a suit in order to trick tony stark into
believing that mandarin was more
powerful than he was but ultimately tony
stark realizes what's going on and then
he manages to overcome the mandarin and
then basically flee away from his castle
but the way this ended was that the
mandarin was just kind of studying iron
man right studying the nature of iron
man's abilities what he was capable of
and then trying to find a way to
potentially duplicate or look for some
future opportunity to reverse engineer
that kind of technology and then
basically find a way to uh to defeat
iron man and then of course expand his
influence throughout the west of the
world but when it came to the mandar
this is one of the big differences
between a lot of the characters that
we've seen iron man face off against
over the years and the mandarin when it
came to people like justin hammer who
was essentially a you know a corporate
enemy and a guy who initiated the armor
wars by having tony stark's armor stolen
and then reverse engineering it
duplicating it and then selling it off
to other villains looking at people like
uh like titanium man you know when it
came to these various forces they were
by all standards of measurements some
variant of tony stark some kind of
duplicate of tony stark even with guys
like the living laser people along those
lines they weren't really major or
significant threats i mean they were
intriguing but when you look at them for
what they really were they really always
kind of felt like villains of the week
when it came to somebody like the
mandarin he was almost every bit as
intelligent as tony stark was not really
on the exact same level but he was
highly capable with his knowledge and
his understanding having spent most of
his life studying sciences engineering
different things like that he was one of
the most mentally challenging villains
that tony stark faced and it's one of
the things that kept him wildly
interesting both among writers as well
as comic book fans because the question
was if anybody's capable of taking out
tony stark will it be the mandrake and
the answer was consistently yeah the
mandarin's the only one who really seems
to have the ability to actually overcome
tony stark and so over the course of
these early issues this really display
of what the mandarin was capable of came
in a bunch of different forms one of the
first things that happened or at least
one of the big things that happened came
in tales of suspense as part of a
three-part story in issues 84 85 and 86
where he actually kidnaps happy hogan
who's wearing the iron man armor
believing happy hogan is actually tony
stark and that ultimately tony stark
manages to rescue happy and basically
blows up the mandarin's castle uh
following that you end up learning that
the mandarin actually has an orbiting
satellite that literally just sits above
earth he fought out of that as a base of
operations for a while in avengers
annual issue number one he actually ends
up bringing together the living laser
the original power man luke cage
swordsman enchantress executioner brings
them together as a singular team to face
off against the avengers and is
ultimately defeated uh an incredible
hulk issue number 107 he teamed where he
tries to bring in the hulk to basically
defeat iron man i mean there's a bunch
of different instances here where marvel
literally just circled this guy around
as fast as they possibly could there was
even a point in uh in captain america
number 125 when you actually saw the
mandarin fight captain america in
vietnam now one of the things that
mandarin had also learned of was that
tony stark was iron man as opposed to
the to the general public's belief that
tony stark and iron man were two
completely different people and iron man
was a bodyguard for tony stark this is
one of the reasons that led to to the
mandarin actually targeting specific
people that tony stark knew in his
personal life and trying to use those as
a means to have these guys fight each
other now one of the things that was
particularly interesting here is that in
iron man issue number 241 really a story
arc that spanned quite a while running
all the way up and even involving
uncanny x-men number 258 uh of course a
lot of this was written by david
miccellini and bob layton as well as
chris claremont one of the big things
that you actually end up seeing is the
mandarin working alongside the hand now
this worked because the hand wasn't
really introduced until 1981
during the daredevil run by frank miller
and of course this comic and story arc
was presented about eight years later in
1989 and the hand had gained a lot of
popularity in marvel comics because of
the work that frank miller had done
those of you guys who don't know what
that is the hand is a mystical ninja
organization that was originally founded
by kaganobu yoshioka in japan really in
feudal japan and was really just at
least initially started as a kind of
coming together of a lot of peasants who
had taken to the mountains to basically
study martial arts when it had been
banned by the japanese government at the
time and so what this led to was the
hand basically making it kind of packed
with what was called the great beast
which basically gave them mystical
abilities and so ninjas of the hand or
members of the hand when they die they
can be resurrected right so the hand is
basically a limitless army and it's one
of these things where the hand usually
uses attrition in order to win right so
if the hand wants to take somebody out
they'll just send in overwhelming force
and so again they're a pretty deadly
organization but one of the things that
made this so intriguing was not so much
that the mandarin was working with the
hand it was the fact that he was
actually lending his rings to members of
the hand which made them even deadlier
and it was crazy because you saw all
kinds of stuff getting involved here
right i mean ultimately iron man ended
up overcoming them all right because you
know an iron man comic
and iron man story but it's one of these
things where you actually ended up
seeing uh at least an uncanny x-men
issue number
258 that you actually saw the events of
the siege perilous playing out now for
those of you guys who don't know what
that is the siege perilous was an
artifact that was given to the x-men by
roma who was basically the founder or at
least one of the co-founders like the
captain written core things like that
but during this time when psylocke betsy
braddick uh when she had basically been
believed to have been killed alongside a
bunch of the other x-men they ended up
passing through the siege perilous which
would in effect allow them to quote
unquote start new lives all over again
this basically led to betsy braddock
just washing up on the shores in in asia
and then in turn having her mind swapped
with uh with quantum and then basically
that led to the japanese version of
psylocke that most all of you guys have
probably seen in your journeys across
looking up comic book characters and
different things like that the mandarin
had a hand in that looking at all these
different events that had taken place
over the course of marvel's publication
history the mandarin had a huge role in
a lot of different events because it
wasn't just necessarily targeting tony
stark it was also doing things like
expanding his sphere of influence into
businesses into governments corrupting
individuals using his power to blackmail
individuals different things like that
there was a lot of stuff happening with
him now a lot of the stuff of the
mandarin came to a head with the heart
of darkness storyline and iron man issue
number 312 by lynne kaminski and the
reality is a lot of this had to do with
force works now for those of you guys
who don't know what force works is it
was basically the result of avengers
west coast after it was disbanded and so
instead of having a west coast avengers
team iron man basically rebranded it
into his own real superhero team called
force works which was pretty popular
when it first came out it was pretty
interesting but the important thing here
is that there was a kind of artifact
called the heart of darkness which was
basically an orb that was composed of
energy and the desire by the mandarin
was to basically use this orb to expand
his power and influence ultimately tony
stark was able to overcome this by
basically turning the mandarin into
something akin to a cyborg by infecting
him with a virus that was one part uh
technology and one part organic we call
it the techno-organic virus but because
of the fact that the orb required a host
that was completely biological it
rejected the mandarin and then when he
was believed to have been dead it
basically just kind of rewind you know
basically wiped his mind of his memories
and he was like a custodian at stark
enterprises right now that was supposed
to be the end of the mandarin one of the
things people don't know is that was
supposed to be the original ending of
the mandarin that was it this being that
was starkly opposed to everything that
tony stark had stood for uh ended up
becoming basically an employee of stark
himself and he was to be written out
completely ultimately this changed
though when marvel launched something
called heroes reborn and hero's return
which was marvel's attempt to basically
do a reboot and rework everybody except
for x-men and spider-man by literally
putting those guys in an alternate
reality it was okay they tried to rework
the mandarin it really wasn't all that
great didn't really do much to make it
work and so the mandarin was just kind
of a character that quite literally just
sort of floated around in marvel comics
for about a decade and a half he did a
few things here and there and some stuff
happened but none of it was of any real
note instead it's not until you get to
invincible iron man vol 2 and issue
number 33 written by matt fraction that
you actually end up seeing the mandarin
becoming probably one of the cooler
characters that marvel's had for quite
some time and a lot of this kicked off
with a story called the long way down
which actually saw the mandarin freeing
ezekiel stain the son of obadiah stain
who had long since been an enemy of tony
stark now this had all happened in 2011
right so about two years before iron man
3 and so as we know when it comes to
movies movies are usually planned out or
the initial phases are usually put
together about three years before you
start like the production process and
casting and all that kind of good stuff
and so if i'm a betting man i would say
that even if marvel wasn't hell-bent on
having the concept of the mandarin being
a part of iron man 3 it was certainly a
talking point i mean i could be entirely
wrong and it's just it would have made a
cool story and it did it made a pretty
interesting story here and the reason
why is that for those of you guys who
are unfamiliar with matt fraction as
opposed to a lot of comic book writers
who write their stories like six maybe
seven issues at a time matt fracture
would write his stories 12 issues at a
time so technically it would be split
into like a six issue story arc but that
story arc is part of a much much much
bigger story arc and it all kind of
comes together at the end and what you
end up learning here is that when the
mandarin freed ezekiel stained he had
also kind of subjugated him to a degree
and that the two of them working
together basically saw them repurposing
and reworking a lot of tony stark's
enemies who were out there right
blizzard the dreadnoughts living laser
the whole nine yards and these were all
villains that over the years had kind of
been goofy and silly and not really
villains that you took seriously but
because of the enhancements that were
given to them between ezekiel stain and
the mandarin they became a lot more
dangerous and so it was really just
reorganizing stark's villains and then
having them launch a series of attacks
at the same time it was also a publicity
attack in the sense that the mandarin
had basically used a photo of iron man
to make him look drunk and then in turn
because of the fact that the concern was
that tony stark had gone back to the
days of alcoholism that the us
government forced him to build an
automatic shutoff for a remote shutoff
for the suit which was used by the
mandarin and ezekiel stain and then
ultimately tony stark quote unquote died
and this led to james rhodes basically
becoming the new iron man now a lot of
this was just a great big huge rouge
that tony stark had pulled against the
mandarin tricking the mandarin into
believing tony stark had died uh in turn
having like james rhodes become the new
iron man secretly all that kind of stuff
eventually the ruse was discovered by
the mandarin and what you ended up
finding out is that this whole entire
set of events as it was orchestrated by
the mandarin was not done explicitly for
killing tony stark instead it was done
for building something called titanomex
which were basically what you think
these gigantic suits that were actually
going to serve the purpose of allowing
the spirits of these warriors in these
rings that have been controlling the
mandarin to basically occupy these suits
and then you know initiate their own
campaigns whatever it is that they
happen to be now initially this was
somewhat ended it was somewhat defeated
but then uh the mandarin got his hands
on tony stark and then forced tony stark
after basically brainwashing him taking
over his mind to finish these titanomex
suits and so ultimately tony stark ends
up breaking free of this mind control
along with ezekiel stain and then tony
stark and ezekiel stain actually gather
together all the villains that tony
starks historically fought and then they
all take out the mandarin which was cool
it was a really really great story it
was it was amazing in terms of how it
had all been done and in fact the
mandarin himself was basically killed by
ezekiel stain in invincible iron man
number 526 now following that what
actually ended up happening during world
war frank uh which was part of punisher
volume 12 by matthew rosenberg you
actually saw the mandarin come back but
in reality not a whole lot really
happened here that story was written in
2018 and we don't really know if the
mandarin is going to have any other
significant roles in marvel comics at
least not that i'm aware of right i'm
not aware of the mandarin having
returned if he has well then i guess i
need to get caught up
it is difficult to keep up on all marvel
comics everywhere all the time it is
tough to do but regardless the mandarin
has historically been a highly capable
foe of iron man and that's what really
differentiated him from a lot of people
and it's one of the things that
potentially would make him so cool in
the mcu and this guy's got his hands in
everything if it's a criminal element in
the world he's involved with it in one
way or another whether it's to expand
his fear of influence or to find a way
to kill iron man it all basically
amounts to the same thing but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end thank you guys for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace
you